>> From the library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ron Charles: Our
guest today is Dan Chaon.
>> Chaon: Chaon.
>> Ron Charles: Dan Chaon.
Thank you so much for
being with us today.
>> Dan Chaon: Well, thank you, Ron.
I'm really excited to be next to
one of those endangered species,
the book editor, which
is incredible.
I'm glad to be able to just like
touch you while you're still here.
>> Ron Charles: Like
finding a panda in the wild.
>> Dan Chaon: It is.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
I'm glad to me you finally
because you've been scaring
the hell out of me for years.
>> Dan Chaon: Thank
you, my pleasure.
>> Ron Charles: You're the kind of
person who says, "I always wanted
to write a serial killer
novel," yeah.
Dan is the author of three
short-story collections
and three novels, including "Among
the Missing," which is a finalist
for the National Book Award.
His stories have appeared everywhere
including the best American short
stories, Pushcart Prize Anthology,
the O 'Henry Prize Anthology.
He teaches Writing at Oberlin
College in Ohio and his new novel,
which is fantastic and completely
unnerving is called, "Ill Will."
Some of the scariest
writers in the country think
that you are really freaky like
Peter Straub, Stephen King.
They all think you're terrifying and
you said once, "I've always thought
of myself as a kind of
ghost-story horror writer."
What draws you to those
kind of stories?
>> Dan Chaon: I don't know.
I think I've always been interested
in scary things since I was little,
and I mean I suppose there's an
element where if you're the creator
of the scary things, then the
scary things won't get you.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dan Chaon: Right?
I mean it's like the person who
makes the haunted house knows
where the ghosts are hidden.
>> Ron Charles: Was something
scary in your youth that made you?
>> Dan Chaon: I grew up in
western Nebraska, so that's --
>> Ron Charles: Oh, yeah.
It's scary enough.
>> Dan Chaon: -- it's scary enough.
I mean I also think if you have
some element of trauma in your life,
there's kind of dialysis
that happens with scary stuff
that it sort of gets the
poison out in some ways.
>> Ron Charles: You
find it cathartic
to write these scary stories.
>> Dan Chaon: Yes and to read them.
>> Ron Charles: As a child,
were you drawn to scary stories?
>> Dan Chaon: Very much so.
I used watch "Night
Gallery" with my mother.
>> Ron Charles: Oh, yeah.
That was spooky stuff.
We're about the same
age, I think, yeah.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: There are
moments in your novels
where suddenly one the
characters realizes
that what he thought was happening
is not really what's happening,
which is sort of traditional
in these kind of stories,
but what you do so well for
the reader, is make us realize
that we thought was happening
is not really happening.
It is amazing technique.
Do you plan your novels out because
some of them like "Ill Will,"
seem so complex to me that I
wonder what kind of, you know,
massive plan you must
have on the wall.
>> Dan Chaon: I don't plan
anything out in the first round.
>> Ron Charles: Really?
>> Dan Chaon: At all.
>> Ron Charles: it just happens.
Dan Chaon: I just happens, and
that's how, for me, there's a kind
of excitement in discover as things
go along and as just things emerge.
So with this particular novel, I did
not have any idea who the killer was
and so I got to the end and then I
had to go back and do a draft and,
you know, do a redraft and sort
of make things work together
as best I could, so, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: We live in a
time between literary fiction
and genre fiction seem
really porous.
People cross back and
forth all the time.
You write, what we would
call, "a literary thriller."
It's kind of a tortured term.
>> Dan Chaon: It is.
>> Ron Charles: But do you think
about genre when you're writing?
Do you think, "I'm now
writing a thriller.
I am now writing a literary novel?"
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I think
of genre in that I came
out of genre-oriented childhood.
The stuff that I started reading
like Ray Bradbury, Shirley Jackson,
Stephen King, Peter Straub.
And that was my first love
and then when I got to college
and it started turning in the
stories in my creative class,
they were like, "We
don't really do this."
And so then I discovered people
like Raymond Carver and Alice Monroe
and I started to sort of
like using them as models,
but I found once I started
writing professionally,
I was still really attracted to
that stuff that I read as a kid
and the stuff that most
influence and I found myself sort
of going back to that
with maybe this
"literary aspect" in my as well.
So I mean it feels like
it was just part of my DNA
from the beginning as a writer.
Ron Charles: And a bunch of
talented people are now doing this.
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: It's
a great exciting time.
It was silly to separate
that stuff out.
>> Dan Chaon: I think so too.
>> Ron Charles: When we start
reading a mystery though,
there is a contract with the reader.
You know where this is going.
>> Dan Chaon: Yes, I do.
>> Ron Charles: We expect to
at least by the end of mystery
to have the mystery solved.
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: You cheat.
>> Dan Chaon: I do not
think -- I mean, look --
I mean for people that want -- I
mean we won't exactly do spoilers.
>> Ron Charles: No, we aren't
going to do any spoilers.
>> Dan Chaon: No, spoilers at all?
>> Ron Charles: But
you do not play fair.
>> Dan Chaon: You're right.
Okay, in some ways, I don't play
fair but I think there are answers
for people that want a
very specific answer.
There are answers for people
that want a supernatural answer
and it's also sort of not fair
for the reader to expect a book
that keeps telling them this is all
about the way the truth
gets distorted
and the memory makes
no sense to expect --
>> Ron Charles: --
everything to be laid out --
>> Dan Chaon: -- everything
to be laid out at the end.
>> Ron Charles: No,
it is not, not at all,
which makes me think the planning
issue must be really complex
as you go back through your review.
Let's talk about this new
novel specifically, "Ill Will."
It's about a psychologist
named, Dustin.
You write, "His brain seemed murky
with circling and unfocused dread,"
which could describe
anyone in Washington now.
Dustin is under a tremendous
amount of stress.
His wife is dying.
His son is spiraling
into heroin addiction.
A number of young men
in the area are drowning
and his adopted brother is being
released from prison after 30 years
because of testimony
that he gave in court,
which he now realizes
provably wasn't true.
That's a really bad year.
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Why
pile so much on Dustin?
What sort of psychological vice
are you trying to create there?
>> Dan Chaon: You know, it didn't
start out to be piling on Dustin.
I just started out with,
you know, like okay,
here's an interesting situation
and here's a second interesting
situation, but I realized
as I was going along that Dustin
was in such a cloud and in --
I feel he's sort of the
stand-in for a lot of us.
I mean he's got so many blinders
on that it's going to take a lot
of hammers and gongs to wake him up.
I don't even know whether he
actually wakes up at the end.
>> Ron Charles: I don't
think he wakes up, no.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, but we
did our best to wake him.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
I mean he's a psychologist
who's totally taken
in by one of this patients.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Which is
standard psychological --
I mean he should be equipped
not to do that, right?.
>> Dan Chaon: He should be.
He is a particular kind of
psychologist -- he's pretty new agy.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: And he
also has, I think,
a tendency to believe his own --
I don't think we can use
the word, "horse pokey."
>> Ron Charles: Yes, okay
but the patient who comes
to him eventually sort of
seduces him into becoming part
of this investigation
to solve these crimes?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, absolutely.
I heard somebody used the term,
"folie á deux," a French term
which means a madness of two people,
where two people get
together and get --
>> Ron Charles: It's a great term.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, and, you know,
where one person's madness
feeds the other person.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: But in another
way, I think if I'd written this
from the patient's perspective, it
would have been a romantic comedy.
>> Ron Charles: Oh,
seducing the therapist?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, I
mean -- it's just the --
yeah, it's kind of a horror
novel from the other perspective.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
You write a lot about --
I can't remember the term,
but sexually repressed memories
or memories of sexual abuse.
There is a term.
>> Dan Chaon: It's -- yes,
it's satanic ritual abuse.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
I'd never heard of such a thing.
I had read about those cases,
but I didn't realize
it was a clinical term
that eventually became
sort of debunked.
I mean -- I think it's--
>> Ron Charles: This was in the 70s?
>> Dan Chaon: It was in the 80s.
It was in the 80s and 90s.
>> Ron Charles: Cases, you
remember them where, you know,
these kids would start to testify
that their daycare worker had
abused them and then, you know,
all 30 kids would recall
having been abused.
They were increasingly
bizarre stories.
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I mean I
think it was during a period
when we were trying to come
to terms with this concept
that childhood sexual
abuse was happening.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: And I think it was
a lot easier for a lot of people
to believe that they was a shadowy
network of Satanist doing it
as opposed to a family member, which
is what the case is most often.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
So this gets you into this whole
idea of how memory is distorted,
how we create our own
past, how foggy that is.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
>> Ron Charles: This
is a fascinating issue
for a novelist who's creating
everything from scratch.
>> Dan Chaon: Well,
it's a fascinating issue
for anybody who's trying
to sort out who they are
and where they came from, and I
think we've all had the experience
of being at the Thanksgiving
table and talking about something
that happened to us when we were
a child and having our cousin
or our brother saying, "No, actually
that wasn't what had
happened at all."
>> Ron Charles: Yes or we project
ourselves into photographs.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
>> Ron Charles: We
couldn't have remembered.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
My sister still claims she remembers
things that happened to her
when she was three and I
just don't believe her.
>> Ron Charles: No.
>> Dan Chaon: But, you know, that's
not to say that things don't happen,
but that we build our sense of
identity around particular memories
and we shape those memories
to confirm what we
believe about ourselves.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: We may repress
memories of bad things that happened
to us but we may also repress
memories of bad things that we did.
I think that's often more
likely, where if there's something
that we did that kind of
goes against who we think
of ourselves as, you know, we
tend to forget about those things.
So it may have been that you were
a horrible bully as a child --
>> Ron Charles: I think I was.
>> Dan Chaon: -- but do you know?
Ask your little sister?
>> Ron Charles: So much of
this now is how we think --
how we come to think we know
what we are -- who we are and --
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: --
how distorted that is.
You write, "Most people seem to
believe that they were the experts
of their own life story, that
they had a set of memories,
that they strung like beads and
this necklace told a sensible tale."
That's not the case of course.
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I think we live
several hundred thousands hours
of time, you know, and of that how
much we remember is pretty limited
and of those memories,
the ones that we choose
when we create our biography
is even more limited.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: So what we're
doing is we're picking
and choosing what parts of our life
really represent our conception
of us.
>> Ron Charles: Like
novelist reading a story --
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: -- it
makes some sense to us.
>> Dan Chaon: Most of
the time, it makes sense.
<< Ron Charles: Yeah and
Dustin, as a psychotherapist,
is all about getting beneath
those things -- those conceptions.
>> Dan Chaon: Right, but Dustin has
an idea that we choose the stories
that we -- we choose the
meaning of the stories
that we tell about ourselves.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: So I think he
says early on to a patient
that the stories that we
tell ourselves having meaning
because we choose to give it to them
and what meaning we choose
to give it is up to us.
>> Ron Charles: That
seems naïve to me.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, it is, but he's
had success with this kind of --
>> Ron Charles: -- quackery.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, it is
quackery but there seems
to be a lot of that even today.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yeah. Grief runs through the novel.
It's a distorting force
in the novel.
It's certainly a distorting
force in Dustin's life.
It's been a terrible
force in your own life.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
>> Ron Charles: You could
have written a memoir.
You may some day.
>> Dan Chaon: No, I never will.
>> Ron Charles: You never will.
My question then is why
did you choose to write
about the horrible experience
in your own life in terms
of fiction instead of
in terms of nonfiction?
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I think -- my
wife died in 2008 and afterwards,
you know, I had a really rough time,
and I was interested in figuring
out a way to write about that and
to write about the kind of feeling
of losing control or going
adrift without writing something
that was autobiographical, and
also writing about it in a way
that allowed me to kind of let it go
a little wilder than I actually did.
I mean I stayed pretty like
grounded through the whole thing,
even though, in my head, I was like
kind of running around screaming
and killing chickens but
the novel kind of allowed me
to explore the further edges of it,
and I guess that's what
I mean by dialysis.
That horror can create a
certain kind of dialysis
and that exploring this stuff in a
genre context allows you to ake it
to the extremes that maybe it
feels like it sometimes as opposed
to what happens in real life.
I don't think a memoir
of my experience would
really do that much.
>> Ron Charles: It would
just be living it again.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah and it would
also be like he sat looking
at the window and then
the next day --
>> Ron Charles: You were
right about the memoir.
I have no doubt about it,
but I can see emotionally,
it wouldn't be the same at all
as writing about it in fiction.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
I mean I do think that finding
this particular container
for things, which is a horror novel.
It's a serial killer novel
and it's, in some ways,
it feels like the right
emotional container for it even
if it's not an autobiographical
container.
>> Ron Charles: In certain parts of
the book and it's hard to explain
but you started to write in columns.
There were three columns across the
page and there are different voices.
Sometimes it seems like
maybe it's the same person
with two different voices.
It's really complicated and
really cool and you have to sort
of teach yourself how to read it.
How did you come to that?
>> Dan Chaon: I actually
started out with an exercise
that I had my students do, which was
to write a story that was contained
in boxes and I got that idea
from a chapter of Jennifer Egan
"Visit from the Goon squad."
It's the chapter that's
written in PowerPoint.
Do you remember that?
>> Ron Charles: I do very well.
>> Dan Chaon: And so I had my
students doing this exercise.
I loved what they were doing.
>> Ron Charles: What do
you mean boxes though?
I don't understand.
>> Dan Chaon: I just had
them make six boxes on a page
and I told them each box had
to contain one scene, so --
>> Ron Charles: -- of the same -
>> Dan Chaon: -- of the same story.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Dan Chaon: So I just loved what
I was getting from them out of this.
I mean it seemed like there was
a really nice kind of interplay
between the scenes that
were put together on a page,
and then I was like, Oh, this
is what comics do, right?
Comics have these boxes that
have an interplay between them
and sometimes it's time
and sometimes it's space,
and sometimes it's a
different perspective
but I was really fascinated by the
way having something side by side
on the page could create
some kind of interplay
and I could replay the same
scene with some contradictions
or replay the scene from
slightly different perspective,
and I like that.
>> Ron Charles: It's
very fascinating.
>> Dan Chaon: I really found it fun.
I was aware -- my editor was
like, "This is kind of difficult."
I think it's -- I mean I
don't think it's that hard.
>> Ron Charles: It's
not the whole novel.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
It's not the whole novel.
It's just parts of it.
>> Ron Charles: It's
a very cool effect.
Very unnerving too as you read
these and they are just sort
of sometimes slightly different.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: But I can see
your editor would push back.
Also it's a layout problem for them.
>> Dan Chaon: Oh, my God, yes --
>> Ron Charles: -- because
of the line up line --
>> Dan Chaon: The typesetting
was crazy.
>> Ron Charles: That's tough.
Jennifer Egan was here a
few months ago talking about
and she gave her draft, and "Visit
from Goon Squad" [inaudible]
about her writing her group
and someone told her she had
to drop the PowerPoint chapter
because it just doesn't work at all.
It's my chapter.
>> Dan Chaon: Exactly
-- it's famous now.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
It reminded me of sort of
the movie, "Split Screen."
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: You
don't see it that often.
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
>> Ron Charles: And it made me
think how constraining the page is.
I mean we all just expect that
and why should it be that way?
>> Dan Chaon: I don't know.
I'm jealous of poets
because they get
to use the page all over the place.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
And novelists, we expect them to
just write in prose like that.
Elizabeth Stout was here earlier
today and she wrote an essay
for "The Post" last week and she
said, "It was until she wrote
"The Burgess Boys" in 2013
that I fully realized what
I was doing with class."
You had said something
very similar recently.
You told an interviewer,
"I've come to realize
that social class is
actually my big subject."
What kind of upbringing
did you have?
>> Dan Chaon: I grew
up in western Nebraska.
My dad was a construction
worker and, you know,
I would say it was a
working class childhood.
Neither of my parents finished
high school and it was sort of both
of my parents had done better than
their own families in a lot of ways.
On my mother's side, particularly,
it was sort of on the edge
of criminal class or,
you know, what I mean.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dan Chaon: So I feel like I
had a very like intense experience
like moving western Nebraska,
where I was the first
person to go to college.
I went to Northwestern, which is a
fairly well-to-do school in Chicago
and then I became a college
professor, and a writer.
There are a lot of distances
and steps between that.
>> Ron Charles: Did it seem
like real work to your dad?
>> Dan Chaon: No, but, you know,
I think it was also just puzzling.
I think it was hard for
people to imagine it.
I mean I had a lot of cognitive
distance myself because, you know,
there were things where
I would be in a situation
that I would not have any kind
of real familiarity
with how to deal with --
>> Ron Charles: -- how to behave.
What draws you to the subject class?
What do you think that's a such
a central issue in your fiction?
When we think of you, we think
of the more flashier things
like the horror, and the
suspense and all that,
but there are these deeper things.
>> Dan Chaon: I think class is a
big issue in America and I think --
>> Ron Charles: Do you think it's
as big in America in fiction though?
>> Dan Chaon: No, I don't.
>> Ron Charles: Why is that?
Is it because our fiction is all
written by upper class professors?
>> Dan Chaon: No, I
don't think necessarily
but I think we romanticize class
in a certain way and I think --
that there's a question of betrayal
that's involved because I think
if you portray like the movement
from, you know, a working class
or a poor class background to
a more well-to-do background,
you're in some way betraying the
romantic notions of like rural life
and rural class life, the
Bruce Springsteen stuff gets --
we're not supposed to
problem-atize that stuff.
>> Ron Charles: So
we just ride it out.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah --
>> Ron Charles: Make it invisible.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
I mean or else we take it
in a more gothic direction.
I mean I think, for example,
"Winter's Bone" is a great book
about class, but there's no
movement out of that class.
>> Ron Charles: Did
you read "Brewster?"
>> Dan Chaon: Yes, a wonderful book.
>> Ron Charles: A spectacular book
about people stuck in a lower class.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: No movement
out of that either except
for the narrator I guess
who's looking back.
Stupid question, but what would you
like to see more in
American fiction?
What would you like to see
to represent more freely,
or more accurately or more fully?
>> Dan Chaon: Well,
we need more diversity
of voices all across the scale.
I mean I think that there is a
tendency sometimes, you know,
like to look to the last big thing
and want to see a repeat of that.
We have a certain kind
of expectation
about literary fiction
should be and, you know.
To me, there's not really a
distinction between literary fiction
and genre fiction because literary
fiction is, itself, a genre.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: And it's a genre
with very, very like rigid tropes.
I'd like to see that the genre
of literary fiction get
broke a little bit more.
Ad I think that's happening
to some extent.
>> Ron Charles: Yes and you're
helping it happen too I should say.
You started as a short-story writer?
I understand you were pretty nervous
about going to the long form.
>> Dan Chaon: It's hard to move
between the short story
and the novel.
>> Ron Charles: You can [inaudible]
the story all at once I imagine;
whereas the novel, as you
said, you can't and you don't.
>> Dan Chaon: I can't and I don't.
I mean I think almost all my novels
have an element a short-story writer
novels because they're broken into
pieces and they tend to have a lot
of stand-alone chapters
and I also tend to write
from multiple perspectives
I think in all my novels
so that I have these very
discreet short-story like chapters
that have helped me kind
of make the transition.
>> Ron Charles: You
camouflage that so well.
I would've never thought of that.
I mean there are writers whose
novels are clearly just a collection
of short stories.
That's not you.
>> Dan Chaon: No --
>> Ron Charles: --
neither [inaudible] mine.
Is this still what you're doing?
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I mean I
think a lot of the novels started
out with short stories like
working parts and then I kind
of sewed them together slowly.
>> Ron Charles: Definitely
-- very, very well.
>> Dan Chaon: Well, thank you.
>> Ron Charles: Now you teach
Creative Writing in Oberlin?
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: I heard
you are immensely popular.
I don't mean to embarrass you.
It's what I'm hearing online.
What makes for a successful
Creative Writing teacher?
>> Dan Chaon: I think being open
to a variety of possibilities
in student work and, again,
not having a clear view
of what the final results should be
and being open to the possibilities
that students can discover
some new aspect of themselves
as they go along and they can
discover things through writing.
I mean the writing is this process
of not just following a set of rules
but a process of discovering
yourself
and discovering what you
want to know and what you do.
I mean I think that's the
greatest thing about writing is
that you can't always know what's
real until you've written it down.
>> Ron Charles: Do
you find yourself --
I mean I had writing teachers
who would not accept any genre.
>> Dan Chaon: Oh, absolutely.
>> Ron Charles: I imagine you're not
that sort of [inaudible] teacher.
--
>> Dan Chaon: No.
>> Ron Charles: -- you accept
lots of different things.
Not to call into question
your profession,
but can you teach someone
to write better?
Can you teach someone to
write a better short story?
>> Dan Chaon: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: You can?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean I think anybody
can write a good short story.
You can't teach somebody
to want to do it though.
That seems to be the trick, right,
I mean because it requires
all kinds of sacrifices.
The first sacrifice is
like you need to want
to spend a lot of time by yourself.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: And you need to want
to spend a lot of time thinking
about an imaginary world that
when you're writing should take
precedence over the world that
you're currently living in.
A lot of people really
don't want to do that.
>> Ron Charles: That's tough
when you're 21 years old.
The world is such a great place.
When I was teaching,
which was a long time ago,
my students wouldn't read enough.
They all wanted to write but
they wouldn't read anything.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Is
this still a problem?
>> Dan Chaon: I teach in Oberlin
College and it's not a problem.
>> Ron Charles: People are readers.
>> Dan Chaon: They are readers.
[inaudible] And they like
to read and I still think
that reading is an important
part of people's lives.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dan Chaon: You know, I don't
meet that many students who want
to be writers who haven't come to
that through a love of reading,
right, because you have to
have the origin story --
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: -- origin
story, I'm sorry.
It's always coming
from, "I read this book.
It changed my life.
It made me feel something
that I've never felt before
and I want to do that myself."
>> Ron Charles: Right, yes.
>> Dan Chaon: I mean you sometimes
get kids who want to be filmmakers
and they don't realize that until
they get to class, you know --
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dan Chaon: -- they realize
that what they were really
inspired by was by movies or TV.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Who teaches you?
Who do you look to?
>> Dan Chaon: God --
>> Ron Charles: You read a lot.
>> Dan Chaon: I read a lot.
I do read a lot.
I mean people that I've loved
recently I mean Jennifer Egan is
certainly one of them.
>> Ron Charles: She has a new book.
>> Dan Chaon: I know.
I'm super excited about it.
the person who just
talked to, Jesmyn Ward,
I think she's a fantastic writer.
>> Ron Charles: She's
a beautiful writer.
>> Dan Chaon: I really like
this guy, Victor LaValle --
>> Ron Charles: Oh, yeah.
>> Dan Chaon: -- I haven't read
his book, but I really like --
>> Ron Charles: He
writes some fantasies.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
I mean it's hard to categorize.
>> Ron Charles: It is.
[Inaudible]
>> Dan Chaon: Kelly Link I think
has a big impression on me.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, she
is incredibly clever.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Would you take
some questions from the audience?
>> Dan Chaon: I will.
>> Ron Charles: There
are two mics here.
Just come up to the mic.
It's very bright, so
wave your hand around.
It's hard to see you.
Yes, sir.
>> Speaker: How you doing?
Ron, I love your work.
I look forward to your
10 best books every year.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you very much.
>> Speaker: Dan, you
mentioned genre.
You talked a little
bit about genre before.
I think one of the best
things about your books is
that they don't read like genre.
It's a good -- it's not a
good serial killer book,
it's just a good book, but
I'm wondering when you write,
are sort of aware of
sidestepping genre cliches?
Are you trying not to
sound like thriller?
Or is it the other
way, do you embrace it?
>> Dan Chaon: Well, I mean I
think with this particular book,
I knew the points that I needed
to hit for a serial killer.
I mean there are definitely
moments that are kind of expected
and so I wanted to build those in
even when I was also doing a kind
of end run around, at
least some of them.
I mean what I was looking at
was that I had the skeleton
of that genre and that I was
putting a different kind of need
on the bones of that skeleton
if that makes any sense.
>> Ron Charles: You read
this book, "Ill Will?"
>> Speaker: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: You did?
>> Speaker: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Did you think
it was incredibly freaky?
>> Speaker: Yeah, absolutely.
>> Ron Charles: Then at the end,
did you find yourself
being really panicky?
>> Speaker: You're absolutely
right about the columns.
That's freaky.
>> Dan Chaon: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: It's like a really
powerful psychological effect.
To do that words, it
seems amazing to me.
Yes, sir.
>> Speaker: Hi, Dan.
Thanks so much for being here.
A lot of writers that
I've heard today tend
to have a unique environment so
they go into when they're composing
and when they're actually
doing their work,
and so what I've heard today is a
lot of the writers like to listen
to music while they're working.
Can you describe a little bit
what your writing environment is
typically like?
And if you listen to
music, who do you listen to?
Who's on your playlist?
>> Dan Chaon: Oh, wow!
I have an attic that I work in.
I usually work late at night.
I usually start working around 11
and go until about three or four.
I started doing that just
because when I had little kids,
it was the best time to have quiet.
I do listen to music.
I usually make a playlist of, you
know, between 10 and like 50 songs
that I'll run through and they'll
be kind of a form of self-hypnosis
because I'll listen
to them so often --
>> Ron Charles: -- they
don't distract you anymore.
>> Dan Chaon: -- they
don't distract anymore.
Some of the music that was on the
"Ill Will" playlist included
Modest Mouse song called,
"Strangers to ourselves"
that is super important to me
and Beach House, the band Red
House Painters/Mark Kozelek.
I guess that's probably enough.
>> Ron Charles: That's very
cool to hear those titles.
Did you publish that list somewhere?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, I think
it's on "Large hearted Boy."
>> Ron Charles: Okay, I had to ask.
He's very clever with those stories.
You've never been in a
sensory deprivation tank?
>> Dan Chaon: No, I've
watched people.
>> Ron Charles: Really.
It's part of the novel.
That's why I'm asking.
>> Dan Chaon: I have like
serious claustrophobia
and it would never work for me
but I have watched the
terrifying You Tube videos
of people enjoying that experience.
>> Ron Charles: Your
book does nothing
to promote sensory
deprivation tanks.
>> Dan Chaon: No, it
depends on whose preceptive.
>> Ron Charles: Anybody else?
Anything at all?
Yes, sir.
>> Speaker: You were talking
about you had characters
who were unreliable, narrators
and tricks of memory and so forth.
Were you inspired at
all by Edgar Allan Poe?
>> Dan Chaon: Oh, absolutely.
I don't think there's any American
who isn't inspired
by Edgar Allan Poe.
I mean for -- I think speaking
of sensory deprivation tanks.
I was probably very, very
inspired by Poe when it came
to that particular -- the
particular kind of claustrophobia.
One of my favorite Poe stories
the "The Cask of Amontillado," --
>> Ron Charles: That's
so terrifying.
>> Dan Chaon: -- which is with a
kind of -- what do you call that?
>> Ron Charles: That's when
he crawls into the hole
in the wall and no response.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: And the story ends.
It's terrifying.
>> Speaker: What about Ligeia --
what about Ligeia or
any of these stories?
>> Ron Charles: Ligeia,
how does Ligeia end?
Remind us.
>> Speaker: Well, anyway, I can't.
It would sort of be a spoiler.
I just want to know if
his work is [inaudible].
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, absolutely.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, I see
a lot of Poe in his work.
>> Speaker: Okay.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, sir.
>> Speaker: Glad to hear you
bringing up Jennifer Egan.
I saw her in Arlington,
which is near here.
You don't live here and told
her I listened to her audio book
and she said to me, "You list
this PowerPoint chapter thing
and if you have a CD,
it's on a CD ROM,"
and you can see it, of
course, so I never --
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
I had the same experience.
I listened to it first in the car.
I didn't get it.
>> Speaker: I then told her.
I said, "I didn't quite" -- so
I've never gone back to the book.
I probably should but I'm
reminded of that because I listed
to "Ill Will" here as an audio
book and a friend of mine said,
"You really need to read the paper.
It's got some weird stuff going on."
So I wondered do you have
any role though in that?
The audio book is very well read.
>> Dan Chaon: I love the audio book.
We talked about like how to
go about doing the, you know,
the sort of strange stuff
that happens on the page,
and we just couldn't figure out
how to get it across in audio
and so we just ended up
having to leave it out.
I do feel bad about it
but I also couldn't think
of any way to get it across.
I mean I think it's a similar issue
for the PowerPoint stuff
in Jennifer Egan used.
It just doesn't translate.
>> Speaker: So you're
saying I missed something.
So I should really take a second
time here now that I got this.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, just glance it.
You can glance at it.
>> Ron Charles: You might have
gotten something else entirely
from the other book.
I heard it's great.
It's got four actors, you said?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, it's
a really good audio book
and there are some really
wonderful performances.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, so that
has advantages the book does not.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Anything else?
Is someone coming up here?
Yes?
>> Speaker: Hi, my question is
how can I be a good supporter
of budding writers
in your household?
So I have a 9-year-old
that's interested in writing
and I have someone else
in my household that's
interested in writing.
So how can I be supportive?
How can I be encouraging in that
regard, especially for a 9-year-old
and not be like helicopter mom?
>> Dan Chaon: Right.
I think it's about reading.
Absolutely, just making sure
that there are books in the house
and making sure that they
have access to the library
and I think creating a
space where there's --
not to say cut out TV and video
games but also just create a space
where there's time to do these
kind of more quiet activities and,
you know, set aside time for that
I think it's really important.
>> Speaker: Right because we usually
have to come in his room at 1:00
in the morning and say, "go
to bed" because he's reading.
So I get that part, so we
just need to figure out how
to put those things on paper.
Thank you.
>> Dan Chaon: Absolutely.
>> Ron Charles: I think
there was someone else.
>> Speaker: I can't imagine
what it would look like,
but you have any interests or
have you ever been approached
to turn your books into cinema,
the screen, or anything like that?
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, I'm working
right to actually "Ill Will" is
under option with HBO to be
made into a limited TV series.
>> Ron Charles: Congratulations.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah, I'm not
sure how that's going to look
if it ever looks like
anything but we'll see.
>> Ron Charles: It could be great.
>> Dan Chaon: Yeah.
It's at very early in the process.
>> Speaker: That's pretty scary.
Good luck with that.
>> Ron Charles: I hope that works.
It's great fun talking to you.
Thanks so much for coming.
I really enjoyed this.
>> Dan Chaon: Absolutely.
[ Applause ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.